hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well one of the most
interesting aspects besides the doctrine
of the mean in Aristotle's virtue ethics
as we find it in nikka mechanics but too
is his specific discussion of these
various virtues separating them out and
talking about them in relation to their
subject matter he's spoken an outline
earlier and then says well we need to
get down to the topic hasta in Greek
down to the specifics about these how
many different virtues can we
distinguish one of the things that I
want to signal which falls outside of
the bounds of this text but at some very
important context is that Aristotle's
not writing in a vacuum the Greeks had
acknowledged a number of virtues
beforehand and talked about them quite a
bit play know Aristotle's predecessor or
you know very famously distinguished the
four cardinal virtues the virtues that
we end up calling cardinal virtues
because there's seem to be most
important a classification that not only
the plainest would use but also the
Stoics plato also he has some of his
characters in his dialogues speak of
five virtues which are the cardinal
virtues plus the virtue
piety is you can fight for example in
The Pretenders now one of the cardinal
virtues they are justice prudence or
wisdom practical wisdom courage and
temperance you notice that Aristotle is
not going to talk very much about
justice until much later in book 5 he's
going to treat it as a separate topic it
is one of the virtues it's actually one
of the most important of the virtues but
he's not going to discuss it very much
in his listing in book two of the
birches he's also going to push prudence
or practical wisdom on into what are
called the intellectual virtues and here
we're discussing the moral virtues so
the two that he is inherent in you might
say from Plato and discussing right at
the start are going to be courage and
temperance he discusses these first in
this listing in book two and then later
on in book three when he begins
discussing the virtues in more depth and
detail those will be the first two that
he's going to address now notice that
I've got them arranged under a couple
different headings we're not going to
worry about others anymore but we're
very interested in how does the
Aristotle lay these out and that gives
you a bit of a clue into why there are
so many virtues for Aristotle he thinks
that it's important to differentiate the
virtues based on what they are actually
about so all of the virtues actually do
have to do with feelings and with
actions but there's some that have to do
even more you might say with feelings or
emotions popping and the actions which
then we we respond to those emotions
with so I was encouraged there was
actually two different feelings the
feeling of fear and the feeling of
confidence which is not the same thing
as courage it's like raw material that
courage works up and with with any of
these we have a mean state right the
virtuous mean like I put here feeling
fear to the right extent at the
time for the right reason and not
feeling fear and at other times likewise
feeling confidence to the degree that
wasn't want to and then responding
appropriately in the action that's what
courage is so that falls under this
category temperance temperance has to do
with the bodily appetites or desires so
the ones that Aristotle consistently
comes back to over and over again are
food taste you know both in the sense of
like filling us up and in the sense of
the good taste drinking you know
particularly wine but we could extend
that to any sort of intoxicating
substance in sexuality which you know
covers a lot of ground we might add to
that some other bodily desires as well
but that desire for them and the desire
not to feel bodily pains is what what
temperance covers good temper or
mildness has to do with our response on
anger one of the the very basic human
emotions
well that plays an important role in not
only ethics but also in the way society
works just think about how much you know
of a role anger plays in politics and
how people post things online you know
if you want to get something viral best
way to do it is appeal to anger as the
research turns out so those are three
different virtues and notice they have
to do with different affective domains
right fear and confidence anger desire
these really basic things these are the
subject matter for an old class of
virgins now he moves on and starts
talking about virtues that they have to
do with X where we can call external
goods that as goods that are not goods
of the body or Goods of the soul but
have to do is a property or wealth or
honor or offices and can actually draw a
dividing line between the two which have
to do with how you dispose of your
wealth and the two which has to do with
honor with with
recognition or respect right so
liberality or generosity has to do with
how on a day-to-day basis you interact
with people in terms of not just your
feelings and actions but the external
goods that you have how do you spend
your money how do you dispose of the
goods that you you possess do you hold
on to them very tightly they're like a
miser
they are you two spendthrift with them
you know sort of indiscriminately
sending them out to the universe is that
some people might say well ever do
pursue the virtuous mean of giving to
the right people for the right reasons
at the right time you know all of that
sort of sort of qualifications
magnificence this is very very
interesting Aristotle thinks that not
only is there sort of a small scale
virtue that anybody can practice there's
also a large scale virtue that is
concerned with we might say public works
with liberality or generosity writ large
within the fabric of society one that he
doesn't think everybody can actually
cultivate because it takes certain
resources in order to do that man
demanding or better better said since I
was tripping over that we're great Solna
switch is what that means that has to do
with honor and the magnanimous person or
the great soul person is actually one of
the ideals for for Aristotle there there
we'll talk to at the end of this about
the unity of the virtuous very quickly
but there is a something out of high
level as well the great soul person is
not very common you know the the
opposite vices would be somebody who
doesn't seek out enough honor for
himself or the more common person who
seeks out too much honor without really
deserving rain an admission is is kind
of a lower level version of the same
thing sort of like it has the same
relation to gratefulness
and liberality has to magnificence
Aristotle thinks that these are
important to cultivate within a person
that these don't just amount to parts of
justice or
these other virtues that these are
distinctive he goes on further this
becomes even more interesting and he
says that there are certain virtues that
have to do with behavior and feelings
and how we use these or regulate these
in terms of social life in terms of life
with other people our amusements our
day-to-day life with them one of these
he calls truthfulness and by this he
doesn't just mean telling the truth in
general a lot of it would fall under
justice for him he means telling the
truth about oneself in what you say and
how you behave and I would be sold so I
would be willing to go so far as to say
for us how we consume what our spending
habits are do you you know do you say
what you really are or are you
pretending to be something different but
your pretend to be better protected to
be worse
that's an interesting virtue right there
irreducible to these other ones good
humor Aristotle is one of those few
people among virtue ethicists who
actually highlights the fact that having
a sense of humor is something good and
it is part of a fully human life we want
to have Pleasant you know pleasantries
and enjoyments and joking around that is
hurt of a full life or aerosol we don't
wanna go too far with it and be you know
the way some comics are not nice people
they some are though it's a find them in
friendliness this is also a birch your
friendship is something that Aristotle
will be talking about as is something
that different but friendliness is a
virtuous state that has to do with how
do you get to react with other people
Aristotle thinks that these virtues of
social life these virtues
how we do with external goods they are
distinct domains of our existence and we
need to take them seriously if we want
to cultivate human excellence now I
mentioned that I would I would say a
little bit about the unity of the
virtues at the end aristotle seems to
suggest at certain points that there
might be three candidates for what would
count as the unifying virtue that would
encompass the rest
Prudence's is he says required for the
virtues and we'll talk about that in
another video just as he talks about in
its complete sense as being all the
virtues practiced in relation to another
and magneto manatee or or great-souled
Ness also is a candidate for having all
the bridges at least in that sense the
great sole person would be great sold by
having all the virtues but all of them
are distinct from each other and
Aristotle thinks it's important to focus
on each one individually as well as to
try to cultivate them all together